I'm a my name is I mention faites I was
Morris college point 12 and I am
involved here with Yale tech the I'm
actually really excited for the next
talk it's very in keeping with the theme
of changing the face of tech and and
this time from the angle of impact and
I'm very glad that the end of the last
talk touched on you know the huge appeal
of technology to impact people's lives
on a massive scale and I think that's
been the draw of tech since the
beginning and maybe even a good old mr.
Morse code you know was excited about
the idea of like impacting
communications around the world when
human to that but there there has also
been this realization over I maybe
decade 20 years that in spite of
increased productivity thanks to
technology you know we haven't seen the
benefits of that productivity impact
everyone's lives the way people were
thought it would and in fact we see no
rising inequality and and so investors
and entrepreneurs are increasingly
interested in applications of
technology's impact everyone's lives for
the better and so you know the what's
example of medicine that came up that's
real exciting one education technology
is really big and then there's also
another area called Civic tech which is
you know putting servers their
technology to the service of governments
and the two next speakers are maybe some
of the most qualified people in the u.s.
to talk about that so I'm really excited
to hear them have a conversation about
Civic tech the interviewer is going to
be miles Lassiter who is very well-known
actually for his ventures in education
technology he was the founder of the
company called hire one which he took
public and I you know that one had also
its recognition for being a very fast
growing company now he
has another company hire one Education
Network sorry that's not very name
another education company one year
racing network can I do but he also sits
on the board of another company he
founded called see click fix which was
very visionary company when it was
founded because he was taking a
crowdsourcing and local mobile
technology and putting it to the service
of City governance a--'s and public
infrastructure and he still sits on the
board of sequel fix he's going to be
interviewing agenda palak who is the
founder and executive director of Code
for America which is a fellowship
program specifically focused on Civic
tech and improving cities through
through technology before that she was a
deputy CTO at the White House Office for
Science and Technology Policy and she is
also aside from her remarkable career
internet famous for a very successful
type talk I called coding a better
government which you should definitely
take a look at it if you're not already
familiar so with that please welcome
miles anja thank you for having us so we
heard a little bit in the introduction
about Code for America maybe that's a
place to start tell us more about the
organization nope known for the
fellowship but also the other programs
would be great to hear about yeah so is
anyone here heard code from America
before and you don't raise your hand
Jessica he's one of our fellows
excellent good well for the rest of you
we should call ourselves the Peace Corps
for geeks do you check to that because I
know Jessica Cole here is not normally
geek but she is definitely helping the
city that she's working with Kansas City
so instead of getting people to go to
developing world we get people with
technical and design and other sort of
tech industries skills to go work with
city governments because they need some
help often Jessica for example is
working with see
Kansas City and they have a lot of
problems with the immunization records
for kids in their school causing a lot
of problems for a lot of people
particularly in wentzville starting and
she's only been there with them for a
couple months in our days with helping
sort out how to not have everybody all
the parents waiting in line right before
the beginning of the school year to get
their kids shots to get their
immunization records and actually make
sure that we do know that kids in school
are immunized which is sort of the
problem the real problem at the end of
the day is we sort of don't know this um
so it's one example of what we're doing
we've been doing this since 2011 had
five classes of jessica's classes the
sixth class of code for america fellows
and because we've been doing it for a
long time working with about a hundred
different cities some of our projects
now as miles was mentioning are sort of
living on past the year that the fellows
work with the cities on them and i can
talk a little bit more about those but
they're we're really deepening our work
particularly in social services this may
surprise you but do you have anybody
hear of any idea how much the government
spends on the social safety net a year
it's about four hundred and seventy
billion dollars if you take all of the
money that americans donate to charities
it's about 42 billion so for every
dollar of charitable money we are
spending 11 government dollars and we're
not getting the outcomes that we should
for that so we've increasingly been
working on projects like a better way to
get on food stamps here in San Francisco
that the fellows started in 2013 but now
we're continuing on and spreading to
more and more California counties and
hopefully the rest of the country soon
so what do you think of the barriers for
governments to do these projects without
a code for AmeriCorps why aren't they
more successful with these dollars today
well governments have a lot of
constraints and how they work and
probably most people in the room could
put a point to some of them it's
SeeClickFix you think you
team became very familiar with
government procurement and had some good
hack surrounded as many of the startups
now have figured out SeeClickFix was
really one of the first procurement one
I think really the the biggest thing
though is that government workers have
often felt very risk averse and I think
one of the things I always like to tell
people is that the risk aversion of
government is not really something we
should blame on public workers the
people who create that risk aversion or
the public because we're very very
critical of government and we tend to
box them into a corner if you are afraid
of a negative story you are going to
make sure everything is compliant and
checks all the boxes and maybe not be
able to sort of get around those
constraints that put you in a position
to actually be able to get the outcome
that you were intending to do so we're
really doing is for helping them think
about the needs of the user how to get
to the outcome and deal with all of the
compliance issues along the way but put
those second to user needs how do you
think about or measure the impact that
you've had that code for america so
we've been measuring the impact in a lot
of ways one of the big things is just
the talent pipeline particularly of tech
and design professionals into government
about 55 people so far I've come through
a program and then ended up in great
positions particularly chief data
officer positions this is something that
didn't really exist until 2011 or so you
might have known that your city had a
chief information officer a chief
communications officer but starting you
know in with the open data movement we
actually started seeing cities create
chief data officer positions and several
of them are held by former Code for
America fellows they're also in
positions like chief performance offered
she's innovation officer analysts
digital services groups that are modeled
after what we did in federal government
so talent is a really big one we're also
looking at just the apps that go into
government whether they're sustained and
we're looking at the number of people
around the country
who do this outside of the fellowship so
Jessica for example was able to take her
off and come to us for the whole year
and she's back and forth between San
Francisco and Kansas City we've got
people in communities who want to do
this kind of work and want to help their
community and their local government
doing apps and data and other kinds of
tech and oftentimes just design
interventions and they're doing that you
know Tuesday nights in City Hall for
instance actually it's it's Tuesday
nights in Oakland and wednesday nights I
Code for America here in San Francisco
there's about 50,000 people around the
country who volunteer on this basis and
those are called our code for america
brigades so we're also measuring that
the growth of that network and the
impacts of that network yeah I think
that's an incredible number of people
who are engaging in it in a way that
didn't really exist before in helping
governments be more effective rather
than you know signing a petition or you
know something else to shake the
government into performing better
actually volunteering in that way and
particularly around these kind of design
tech innovation areas i think is
fascinating you alluded a little bit to
your digital service work they did
personally and the federal government
maybe could tell people more about that
as well sure so I started Code for
America in 2010 and we had our first
class of fellows in 2011 so we were a
couple years into it when I was
approached friends just at the end of
the first Obama administration about a
program that would have been started
really modeled after Code for America
but within federal agencies the guy who
approached me is a guy named Todd Park
who was at the time the chief technology
officer of the United States is an
amazing title it's a great title yeah
and you know we never had them before so
prior to the Obama administration there
were CIOs and some
x CTOs in in the agencies but there was
no overarching CTO or CIO and so Obama
if I had that tile I'd be inclined to
introduce myself as V CTO these periods
just drop yeah yeah I yeah I was the
deputy's one of two so you can't even do
yeah it doesn't work quite the same uh
anyway so todd todd was the second
person to hold that seat one of the
things he did was create a program
called the presidential innovation
fellows much like code for my reco
fellows and he asked me to come help run
it and actually didn't want to do that i
love the presidential innovation fellows
and i did end up working really closely
with them but i really wanted I figured
though I didn't want that job and didn't
want to move to DC I did want to
advocate for something that I had seen
in fact it is actually where I was when
he called me i was at the government
digital service in the UK where instead
of having with innovation teams trying
to create open data programs and spur
innovation they actually sort of
centralized the authority for all
digital spend in one place in the
Cabinet Office and it says if you took
all the federal agencies and said nope
you're all doing this this way they
hired a guy who was the former head of
digital for the Guardians we came from
the consumer tech industry and they've
been completely transforming digital
services for British citizens or in the
public in a way that really looks a lot
more like a consumer app much simpler
easier to use actually cost a lot less
to have these better systems and I had
never seen anybody do it on such a scale
in so well and I was so impressed with
it I said Todd you really need to have a
version of this in the US that you know
sits in a central place of authority can
really start to change how we do tech in
the United States and so
long story in there where I did finally
agree to go I traveling across the
country every week is a little bit tough
like many you've probably lived in two
places at once like many of my friends
say I'm just waiting for the year i have
a one hair dryer life but we managed to
do all that and got to DC and against
the short version of the story is I
don't think anything would have really
happened with my grand plan that people
thought was a nice idea but wasn't a
really high priority until October first
2013 which was what the day that we shut
down the government and the day that
healthcare.gov launched didn't go so
well and suddenly there was a much
greater understanding that in fact if we
can't put up a website that works we
can't govern we can't actually implement
the laws that we have spent like you
know many years and all of our political
capital to to pass and then there was a
lot more energy and enthusiasm for what
we had proposed which was the United
States digital service we finally got
that stood up just as i was returning
back to code for america i had a year
leave of absence but it's now a very
successful exciting unit within the
White House that works with the agencies
that need it most to get their tech
right so Department of bed particularly
the Veterans Administration still works
with the Health and Human Services on
healthcare.gov a number of other a real
key priorities and we were able to build
a complementary organization within the
general services administration that
does very much the same work but in a
little bit of a different basis so
they're kind of work very closely
together as unit called 18f and the
United States digital service and if
you've seen for instance than new tools
that came out for vets gov it looks
different it works veterans can sign up
for health care the stuff is actually
starting to work because we've got the
best people on these
on these really difficult challenges and
they're breaking down the barriers
within the organization to just get it
done and have things work for people who
need them so we're among friends right
CL network you can tell us the secret
how do you get cheaper better faster
technology projects done in a government
environment with them it would be hard
to do government technology projects for
more expensive than they are part of it
is that the bar is kind of low the bar
for cost is lower high depending we talk
about these things are insanely
expensive nobody knows how much
healthcare.gov cost but it was certainly
upwards towards a billion dollars all
told the Veterans Administration spends
just massive amounts and I'll talk a
little bit about a project we just
worked with the state of California on
that was going to be starting at six
hundred million the online form that you
use today if you're trying to apply for
food stamps in California which is 50
screens long and asks a couple hundred
questions just to apply for food
benefits it's unusable and almost no one
who starts it ever gets through it but
taxpayers here are paying 80 million
dollars a year just to maintain it you
can't it's not even being built it's
just the maintenance contract is 80
million dollars a year so pretty easy to
do better than that if your question
sorry I kind of took that a different
direction so I know what you really
meant which is how do you get it done I
was being kind of quick but we're
talking about breaking down barriers and
getting a new talented is that all it is
if what are those barriers yeah and I
think the thing that code for america
fellows have shown me over and over
again and presidential innovation
fellows and folks who work at 18f is
there's a number one thing that crosses
all of these units all of these groups
all of these volunteer groups but
everybody in the Civic tech space and
it's start with users so you've got to
stop thinking about your 50 page use you
know requirements actually sometimes
five thousand page we're
requirements documents and start
thinking about the person that you're
trying to serve and what's the critical
minimal thing that you can provide them
that will actually work and talking
about users and demonstrating what users
go through is kryptonite especially at
places like the VA we you know the we've
just got a big win over there the other
day in part and it was formed for
applying for health care that literally
just hasn't worked for something like 10
years and the team went out and found a
homeless veteran and had a camera and an
audio and a screen you know screen share
thing and just documented this veteran
trying to sign up for health care every
step of the way and then showed it in
staff meeting and it's like you know
when you can demonstrate know it really
just doesn't work there and then
demonstrate that we have another
solution you can get the solution turned
on on the old one turned off but it can
be very difficult the other thing is
government's really used to planning we
do a lot of planning in government and
what fellows will do is instead of
planning they'll just build a prototype
and sometimes it doesn't even work
sometimes it's like it's slide where in
other words it looks like it's a nap but
it doesn't have any functionality yet
but the minute people see that there's
something that could be better that
could actually get the job done and then
you know we can say well we'll have the
you know the minimum viable product of
it up in a couple weeks it just
completely changes the conversation from
what are the barriers to how can we just
get how can we get that can we get that
you know when can you have it and sure
those barriers come back but you're just
having a different conversation what was
it like to leave an organization that
you created to go on your own fellowship
here well it turned out to be certainly
the most interesting year of my life and
I'm very glad I did it and I would
really ended it doing it because here I
was encouraging people to go do public
service and I'd never worked in
government I felt like a bit of a
hypocrite and it was hard to leave the
org though and I think
and I wouldn't recommend to any
entrepreneurs did go you know a couple
years into building your organization
leave for a year and come back and under
ideal circumstances but I'm certainly
glad I did it I certainly feel like
while code from America took a little
bit of a pause while I was gone the
whole network of people doing this work
through so much and we're so well tied
to them right now that it's it's it in
the end we will do better work because
of it and actually let me give you an
example of how working in federal
government helped coach r America do a
better job in the long run and it's
another one of those horror story i know
people tend to like at the end of last
year at state of california asked us to
help them with a procurement that they
were doing for the child welfare system
the software that social workers and
others use to deal with the 475,000
reports of abuse and neglect of kids in
California today has been out of federal
compliance for a long time and the
state's been trying to put together a
new RFP to to build any system and that
is this has been a very uh non going
chronic problem for the state it's a
very big problem for social workers who
just essentially have no working
software we looked at their RFP and it
was all the hallmarks of a failed IT
projects IT projects in government have
about a ninety four percent failure rate
anyway and this was even worse than
average so we said it's not going to
work on your see what it's what's worse
than blowing the six hundred million
dollars that you're going to blow is
that six years from now you won't have
you still won't have anything that works
and yours to be starting over and that
six years is a lot of reports of abuse
and neglect it will not be handled as
well as they could so they took our
recommendations and they said they
agreed but then a couple months later
they said well we don't have any other
options so we are going to go forward
with this and I my first time here in
California i worked in child welfare and
i became a little bit crazy about that
decision and made
phone calls in it it turns out that the
guy who oversees the the money that
comes from the feds to the states to
build the system was somebody that I had
worked with at the White House and could
make a phone call to and it sounds like
terrible nepotism but it's all you know
above board and we were able to call
people the state that I knew would care
about this and we were able to help them
rewrite that RFP in an agile modular way
using open source and open standards and
we you know it actually went out as a
completely different RFP based on user
needs and we wouldn't have been able to
do that I would have I think been stuck
in the insanely frustrated place if we
hadn't been able to connect the dots
between what happens at the county level
the state level and all the way up to
the federal level so you're talking
about a case where software impacts the
lives of children families mm-hmm is
that part of what got you into Civic
tech originally I mean to take your
personal story back a little bit further
you know I don't think that I had as
much of a realization of how much
government technology impacts real
people until I got into it I was working
in the tech industry we got into looking
at how governments and it was the
contrast between a sort of web to toe
world and the government world was
really what kind of freaked me out but
we were looking at projects that were a
DoD and they seemed a little bit
abstract it's really when I got into the
work and learned all these things that I
realized and frankly the methodology
that the coat America fellows have
practiced and I won't take credit for me
they the people who came to the really
brought this of a really good user
research when you do really good user
research you find out that this stuff
doesn't work and the the impacts of it
are just devastating on regular people
so we work a lot on unsnap that's the
national program Supplemental Nutrition
Assistance Program hearing
cornea is called CalFresh I had no idea
that half of all Americans will use snap
at some point in their lives that most
kids will that you know when when you
cannot sign up for stamp which is what
California by the way assume most of us
here in California has the second lowest
enrollment rate and snap of any state in
the country because our cut the way you
sign up is so complex and then the way
you finish signing up is even worse you
know if there are millions of
Californians it could be getting food
assistance and the a dot so it was
really getting into this space and
learning more that made me realize this
isn't just about saving money I care
less now about the waste in government I
care about the fact that as as recline
said you know healthcare.gov was on the
front pages but if you're using
government programs you're experiencing
something as bad or worse than
healthcare.gov every day right now even
after healthcare.gov wee man it we
monitor the uptime of snap sites around
this country and it's like it was big
big news that healthcare.gov was down
like you know and it initially was sixty
percent of time and then I got less and
less and less but tons of sites that are
where you would sign up for food stamps
for instance go down every night all
night on schedule they keep banking
hours it's a website that goes down in
five what's the rest is to rest sure uh
well yet so you have to sign up between
those hours and then there's some that
have just been down for several months
and no one knows when they're going to
come back up there's something that just
have very low up time there's something
but all of them whether up or not are
really really hard to use and it
shouldn't be this way for them on minute
he was spending they can done that four
hundred and seventy billion dollars
should buy us a decent app that works
you're here I couldn't agree more uh let
me get off my soapbox well if I could
turn the conversation still a little bit
more personal direction again given that
it's a Yale event would love to hear any
thoughts you have a
how Yale education or network has helped
you in your career um I mean I think
here in San Francisco I've been I kind
of came out here worked in social
services and then ended up in tech media
and then I was like the non-technical
person in tech or many of us are but I
think I've really valued yeah I mean
that was an American Studies major any
other amstud majors in there yeah okay
so we're a small minority hello hi I
always joke that like what do you do
with an American Studies major you found
an organization called Code for America
but I really have valued that sort of
breath of my yellow education and I feel
like the tech you couldn't you know you
can I know there's many a pure science
grads and is I'm not trying put that
down but like I've valued having the
breadth of the Yale education and I know
everybody no matter what you what your
major was just got that that sort of
curiosity about learning and sort of the
variety of perspectives and certainly
the network has has helped that was
joking with Jessica that once again on
the nepotism theme I'm the probably the
third person to hold the title deputy
CTO again because it was a new office
and the first person was andrew
mclaughlin who's not only my year at
Yale but my foot my college so he did
not get me the job did wasn't nepotism
but they're you know they're there have
been many there been many Yale ease and
who you I think signed up for the cause
of Civic tech right well at this point
if you're okay I'd love to open up for
questions from from anyone else
alright cool questions I can stand up
say your name hi my name's Ashley this
is a little bit less of a question more
just a comment because their
organization has really affected long
beach which is where my business is so
we're a Bloomberg grant city at the same
time that we have Dan I assume I don't
know if you know each of the fellows but
he's been there and he has one colleague
so we have the bloom but the Bloomberg
grant come in which infused some capital
to think about technology innovation in
the city of Long Beach we have code for
america i get really serious put two
fellows in town and then last year my
company moved offices downtown and then
opened up our office space on saturdays
so look at the code for america folks
and their recruits the bloomberg folks
and then some of our engineers kind of
teaching each other's craft skills and
then that spawned two or three other
movements of civic hack hacks within the
city so one was focused on the port one
was focused on fisheries and so it's
just interesting to see that all of that
happened very rapidly you know within
about a year and a half and it's also a
really cool model of how kind of
government grant funding private private
money private companies and just
interested individuals you know once
something started like that how they can
really get going so if there's a
question in this really i just wanted to
say it's working so thank you and if
there's a question it's you know if this
is the sort of synergy that you're kind
of running toward do you have any vision
for kind of next steps I mean what
happens once there's projects like this
going on all over the place as far as
sharing that intelligence expanding that
network kind of what's what's next well
thank you for that setup i'll give you
twenty dollars later for
I'm very glad that you're hecka the team
we love working with Bloomberg I team so
you sort of business process
reengineering and then we can sort of
close the loop on actually having tech
that that puts that in place I think
you're at you stories perfect because it
sort of speaks to the twin challenges /
opportunities of our work which is the
job is so enormous we can never hope to
take it on all ourselves so we spend a
fair amount of our resources energy just
trying to create you know help spur that
Civic tech ecosystem and encourage
others to be doing this we spend a fair
amount of time and energy and money or
early on actually running accelerators
and incubators for civic startups and
then when that seemed to sort of be a
thing of its own and there became more
venture capital available to civic
startups actually i would give again see
click fix a fair amount of credit for
seating that we started when cash
seacliff its of what 2010 oh we've I was
actually just looking at the blog post
today we're started working on 2007 2007
okay wait yes way early and way great
because even when we stated in 2010
there was still a lot of like hmm and i
want to put money into a company that's
gonna work with government because
they'll never get paid certainly that's
really changed a lot there's a lot more
civic startups now and a lot more people
doing in a variety of ways whether its
entrepreneurial or volunteer or starting
new groups like ours so we've got to
just figure out how more and more people
go to do this because the again the
problem is so big and then in the work
that we do with the apps and the
relationships with government our future
direction really is around things that
can scale we had hoped to find more
scale within cities and we're really
finding that scaling through programs
that are administered locally but funded
nationally have something in common
because of that national funding and
have impacted scale I mean Snap is is
basically been proven to be the most
effect
way to pull people out of poverty or at
least to keep them falling below the
poverty line it we think we can we can
really tackle programs like that at
scale and then tackle the ones that are
adjacent to them so that's sort of our
future question from Jessica however
here hey Jess hi hai jaan face um so
from the nonprofit sector you've been
able to make these really meaningful
interventions in the public sector but
as you all may have noticed it's an
election year so as we all go out to
vote what do you think we can and should
expect and demand of our public servants
when it comes to technical intelligence
this point again thank you i'll give you
your twenty dollars yeah i mean i'm not
a fan i think i think a lot of people
talked about expecting our leaders and
public servants to be more technical
that would be great but basically say
that it just scares people people who
are non technical or constantly insecure
about it including me so I think it's
really more about demanding that that
public services work and that we put
technology in the role that it needs to
be in in order to get there one of the
things I'm constantly sort of not
surprised by but dismayed by is that we
have such low expectations for public
services um we're like completely
delighted and surprised when you know
there's some DMV's that are doing a
great job right now I has anyone been to
these like fantastic dmvs I think
there's one no there i'm not kidding
there really are a couple i thought was
like her like she's making a joke no
somebody really there's i think there's
one in the peninsula that no yes okay
anyway when you when you have these
experiences and there and there are some
um back over there races head for twenty
dollars okay oh god i only have 60 so
no more payoffs but the wait have you
really been to its San Mateo that's what
I thought everyone go to the San Mateo
D&B apparently it's fantastic um no but
when you do encounter experience like
that you're just completely surprised
and that's part of the problem is that
we should accept this very very poor
interfaces when it just could be so much
better are used to I was not never going
to do this because I want to be very
respectful of government as well but
think like take that your favorite app
that you use and then redesign it as a
government I'm a lift fan for instance
so like what would lift look like it
would be like a form that you would fill
out with like a bunch of things and then
you would get a call later saying that
maybe we're going to get a car I think a
lot a lot of form validation errors on
your address saying that it wasn't
formatted according to usps standards
yeah a bunch of drop-down menus where
you couldn't read the menu items there's
a lot of that um so your application has
been referred for further review yes
like please please call between yeah so
anyway Jessica answer question what I
think what I would most like people to
hold their public servants accountable
to is just the there isn't any inherent
natural reason why public serve digital
services from government aren't as good
as what you're using I don't there are a
couple constraints I get it there's
going to be always a couple questions a
little bit more legal eases than we want
but we should think of them as is better
than we far better than we do we should
think of them as causing costing orders
of magnitude less and we should really
expect the public officials and
government officials who are monitoring
these programs to have real-time data
about whether they are working I care
very much about the user experience but
I also care about the programs that we
put billions and billions of dollars in
having real-time data that will allow us
to know when we need to change to get
the outcomes that we're looking for
yeah and just to just to build on that
you can also just vote I mean some some
cities have I'm from LA and our mayor in
LA two years ago he was running he kind
of courted the tech boat because the
whole texting thing was starting to pop
there and he won one of the first things
he did was he had hired one division to
create an app division governor credit
app we could actually go around take
potholes in LA and they're a lot and
basically at real time like
acknowledgment where the Paul has and
then someone would go and fix it in a
much shorter time and he's also doing
he's also doing things like me it's what
it's see click fix white label yes very
good he's also doing things like City
hackathons where he invites like the
tech community n and basically hack
ideas for fixing transportation fixing
other things and they also has actually
demanded each of his 23 services to get
more tech and to revamp their websites
and some of them supposed to get apps
and so we can't depend on to the city
official and basically vote for the ones
who are more tech and then they won't be
all right so speaking of lift we have a
question from Simon from uber sorry
seven yeah so it's a competitor you can
also get a ride I have heard of it
mostly yeah this is a did say we were
well served with rides I'm glad to hear
it I hope so so I a conversation that I
try to follow its order from a distance
and I don't think I've made a great
position to like a formative solid
opinion on it so I'd love to hear your
thoughts on it is the question of coding
and technical education across the
country if you're in Silicon Valley and
an include tendon Cisco you know it
seems like coding is everything into
like obviously yeah like learn to code
and your life will be the better for
even if you don't necessarily be a
developer but that's because whether
you're working in tech or like a Jason
like it's probably in your around you
but I wonder is that actually like high
hanging fruit when we're thinking of
making a strong economic impact on
communities that are currently under
privileged
we're like maybe even literacy is not
you know coding literacy the actual
literacy is is still a concern is is or
is there hype should we believe the hype
are having are you aware of programs
that seem like they're doing the right
things or where are things that are
they're doing that are wrong in the
whole conversation and process for
expansion coding education well I'll
invite my interviewer to answer that as
well I mean we do see if err.number
programs if a lot of people confuse us
for a program that teaches kids to code
or under privileged groups to code we
don't do that though that does happen
occasionally through the fellowship we
do a lot of community events and I think
actually the underserved community that
we have most taught tech skills to his
mayor's done a lot of like showing
mayor's how to use Google Docs and
things like that we haven't taught
America code yet but I mean I don't
think I have any special expertise to
say you know our special perspective to
inform this opinion but yes I do believe
that you know equal access to tech
industry jobs and to the ability to do
tech is is really critical for quality
in our society and I do think that the
what I again what I've learned from Code
for America fellows is the ability to
sort of prototype something is magic and
if you can do that in your own life it
may not even necessarily be about
getting a job but it's hugely hugely
empowering I don't have any answers in
terms of what works and what doesn't
work that maybe miles does yeah I think
your question was largely around
economic development how do we how do we
spark that and i'm not sure i'm an
expert on that but i think startups are
pretty cool their programs for a Latino
or urban
as neighborhoods to have tech programs
or hackathons or things like that are
there that happening so there are a ton
of those and I don't know if those spark
economic development necessarily but
directly ensued yes I could order
effects may be right nearby here by the
way it's a great organization everyone
to the support called code 2040 does
everyone heard of this so code 2040 is
based on the idea that by the year
twenty forty the tech industry should be
representative of the population in the
United States in gender race ethnicity
lovely woman who runs that name Laura
Wedeman powers there's no musicians like
yes we code there's in Oakland where I
live there's hack the hood which is a
fantastic organization I think as an
observation somewhat self-serving in
terms of reinforcing that point about
the size of government relative to the
size of philanthropy most of these
programs are small they are serving they
start out serving ten kids they end up
serving a couple hundred kids the amount
of money that goes through them is in
the couple of millions on I can't
remember the exact number of top of my
head but like workforce federal
workforce training dollars i think is 14
billion so the federal workforce
training dollars could be applied to
giving people the kinds of skills that
will actually get them a job but they're
not and that's actually one of the
program problems that we're working on
in the fellowship this year partnered
with the city of new orleans that gets a
disproportionate number of workforce
training dollars and yet fifty two
percent of african-american men of
working age are not working this is a
failure of the system so i use it a
little bit to get back on my soapbox
apologies but we should be supporting
those programs that like hack the hood
and code 2040 but we also just need to
make the giant buckets of money we spend
on these problems work great though i
think we had some question for you
go to jail oh sorry I didn't see that
the edges before definite from ballet if
you got to be on camera go ahead and
stand that sucks where you can get the
background how you you I Wizards you
know something probably about coding
back in design and fauna anyway um so
you were saying that we should have high
expectations of government software just
as high expectations as we have of you
know apps that we buy in the store but
it seems to me and maybe you can address
this that government apps and government
websites have to satisfy constraints
that you know private industry can say
well we'll get around to section 508 on
release 2 and the government website has
to satisfy it on release one on the
first day right so there are going to be
constraints that are going to make it
much harder to get that thing you can't
roll it out in version 3 or 4 or 5 you
have to roll it out right away so I I
just want to get your appointment on
that no it's a great point so 508 is
accessibility compliance um yes there's
a lot of constraints so for instance yes
you could in the private sector roll out
an app that was didn't comply with a
bunch of standards that help people who
have limited vision or other ways use
the app and in government you do I think
one of the things that we've introduced
in government not single-handedly but I
think we played a big role in is just ad
at alpha and so what your alpha does not
need to be 508 compliant and if you can
get that app out there and get real
users testing it to figure out the other
usability issues before it goes into a
full release that does have to be
complaint you're going to have a way
better app I actually believe that 508
compliance is great for apps I mean it I
think it's wonderful that you know the
government insists on that you're right
and be something that would be nice to
add on a little bit later but what kills
us now is have is not having any user
testing or any of the least roll it out
until everything is done and I think
we've gotten we've
come a really really long way in
government in being able to just call
something in alpha or a beta and get
users on it before it's hitting that
point where it's checking all the boxes
does that help answer your question cool
we have a question from Tracy who works
at Twitter over here such interest yes
yes I know if anyone needs help signing
up for an account please yes so actually
I just last month being on the IRS
website and at that point where between
me and my husband sitting here I was
like we just need to redesign this we
were having our own moment so thank you
for the organization I think they're
they're doing that there's a design
challenge to redesign that 1040ez or
something like that there's this great
programs that's great assignment anyone
can go go redesign your form and send it
in yes I got stuck in a very painful
login loop it was awful but one of the
questions actually that I have is how
you structure so obviously it sounds
like you've developed a great approach
for how to come in and kind of reshape a
team's thinking about creating a product
and where to start but as we all know
products need maintenance you need to
upgrade you need to constantly be giving
them the care and feeding to keep them
successfully working so how do you do
that kind of after a fellowship is ended
to make sure that the the technology
expertise and kind of the the approach
doesn't leave with it and you make sure
that they're supported going forward and
for the next thing they try to put
together I think this is the last
question but yeah it's a question that
we could talk all day about so it's it's
a fantastic question it's the question
that every code for america fellows
dresses out about from day one it's this
question we stress that about most and
in fact i think you're calling out that
it's the sustainability of the approach
moving forward and the sustainability of
the app that you're trying to balance
just
I were just talking about this her study
partners in Kansas City are really
interested in everything they can get
out of there Code for America two
fellows team they will help them sustain
the approach and that sometimes that
involves training it involves you know
going looking at apps that you weren't
there brought in to look at our problems
that you weren't brought there to solve
on the Sistine and in fact I would say
as much as I'm really really proud of a
lot of the apps that have come out of
Code for America and the impact they've
had the things that government partners
have said to us about the sustainable
you know under the banner of
sustainability of the approach have been
like you know will I make me incredibly
proud there the second year we worked
with a woman in Detroit who said I've
been a public servant for 35 years and I
stopped believing I could serve the
public I now believe I can do that again
you have made me proud to be if it
wasn't we've had such great feedback
about how enabling this is for people
who have really really really hard jobs
and they to a person want to do a good
job at them so that part is so important
and we do struggle with if you have a
team just focus on the app for the whole
year and not do that other hand hold
hand holding is the wrong word but
empowerment work you you could just have
sort of a different balance um the the
short answer about how these things are
sustained is that they've either gone
into startups and spun out we've had
seven or eight of those so far some of
which have been acquired now some of
which are still going concerns in many
cases this is the those two things of
training and the apps or went together
and the local government was able to
sustain it and continue it that means
we've trained IT departments in things
like Ruby on Rails quite a bit we've
trained them in sort of DevOps
functionally that they didn't have
before and in some cases they haven't
survived so there's a there's a wide
range and then and then the third thing
is that there are
smaller set of apps that we are trying
to take very intentionally you know from
jurisdiction to jurisdiction that we
maintain but at the scale that we've
been doing that we haven't been able to
maintain them all well thank you very
much I think some what you said today
about user centric design and making
things more effective ways to reduce
risk by iteration getting in front of
users getting real feedback those I
think are even more important than the
pure like technology skills or DevOps
tips that you give someone and that's
what I hope you keep advocating for
because I think has a really big impact
so I want to temper my cell phone and
I'll please join me in thanking Jen